[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sa musique est un jour on emboîte pillay
neuf mois je vous le dis tout les
chemins elle est là et j'ai tous mes
copains qui se sont cassé les dents sur
elle et j'ai un copain à moi
lui c'est attila ça veut dire si lui ne
pêche pas personne n'empêchera je vous
le dirai et donc qu'est ce qui fait un
peu tard mais il voit que je suis avec
la meuf et ils voient que ça d'être il
dit ça commence à un truc il vient dans
la boîte
je vous jure que c'est vrai je suis avec
la meuf essai c'est chaud ça vient
il vient me voir il me fait je peux te
voir deux minutes sinon mes frères se
faire après on va faire le chemin
ensemble pour un coup on se dira prêt
dit non je veux te voir tout de suite
julien il faut que je te vois il ya une
embrouille vient vite avec moi il m'a
mais des coups droits bien au sort de la
boîte ils m'amènent il me fait marcher
mais bien 500 à 800 mhz et 30 mhz et non
là j'arrive puis séoul en moins évident
mais je crois ça fait trois semaines que
je suis sur la même tu portes une
arrivée du malade
[Applaudissements]
alors hier de la calabre
oui oui à ce jour monsieur je suis
assistant du madame en ayant des
systèmes nomades dément oui mais ce
matin il est dans le région ont sûrement
d'accord oui oui on aime beaucoup le
blizzard d'accord pour cela ils veulent
revenir ce soir le beau jeu blizzard
d'accord oui je pense que oui mais il
n'y a pas tout à fait valable
et sur les infos pour les gens des jo jo
dan dah tsai shu vous parlez des jauges
vacances pendant ces mois battant plus à
tortiller du cul
vous avez déjà changé une couche et
changer une seule fois une couche aussi
ça dort mais c'est pour un chroniqueur
ici
je voulais un truc je vous trouve
meilleur que vous êtes donc moi j'allais
en boîte de nuit à chaque fois j'avais
un truc est jetée roulement il faut pas
jouer avec la nourriture en plus c'est
que j'allais j'allais en boîte et jamais
du saumon fumé sur moi et maintenant sur
la vie de ma mère jamais du saumon fumé
leur histoire j'amenais du saumon fumé
sur moi et pendant que j'avais des
copains sur la liste j'aimerais qu'ils
étaient en baisse mais aussi de ma mère
c'est vrai et dans ces cas c est tout le
monde rigolait et genre le mec croyait
et aux gens des notes venues avec moi et
c'était les stades à tout bois mais les
hommes qui ont été président des ja la
côte énorme
c'est un homme spécial
[Rires]
les fronts
marchons
même chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]